WILLIAM LI: My
name is William Li.
I'm a Ph.D. Student in
computer science at MIT.
And for this course, I
was a graduate instructor
for 6.811, principles
and practice
of assistive technology.
And that meant I was one of
the c-instructors of the class.
GRACE TEO: Cool.
And my name is Grace Teo.
I am a lecturer for 6.811.
And basically our class is
about pairing students up
with clients with disabilities
to create a customized piece
of assistive technology
for them over the course
of the semester.
So the reason why I got
into teaching this course
is partly because of William,
because William invited me.
But also the
background to that was
that over the summer
at MIT, I had founded
a very similar class
called Open Style Lab,
where we teamed up
students with clients
with disabilities as well.
Except that in that case,
we were asking the students
to create clothing for them.
So this entire area
of designing around
a constraints of disability
is very interesting to me
because, first of all, there's
very immediate community
impact.
I think because
of that too, then
the students have
a lot of motivation
to try their best to learn
because they see that they're
really impacting a
real person and helping
to solve a real problem instead
of just doing problem sets
or solving kind of
abstract challenges.
And I think, to be honest,
one of the things I love
is seeing the students
get comfortable talking
to and talking about people with
disabilities over time as well.
Because I think very
often in society
there's a huge amount of
discomfort surrounding
disability.
And it's not that
people don't care
it's just that they don't
want to say the wrong things,
you don't want to
be offensive, and so
equipping our students
with the skills
to be able to engage with the
community is really important.
WILLIAM LI: So I was
fortunate as an undergrad
to work at a children's
rehabilitation hospital
one summer and learn about the
space of assistive technology.
And I ended up doing that
in my undergraduate thesis.
And so when I went
to grad school,
I wanted to continue working
in assistive technology.
And I was fortunate to be
able to do that here at MIT.
So my master's
thesis was working
a lot in speech recognition for
people with different speech
challenges with
multiple sclerosis that
maybe affects their speech.
So I think it's a
really-- similar to Grace,
I think it's a really
fascinating area to work in,
very personally meaningful,
but also very interesting
design constraints
and challenges
in working in this space.
And so with respect to the
class, my master's thesis
adviser Seth Teller started
this class back in 2011.
I was fortunate to
be the first teaching
assistant in the class.
And then to get involved
in it with a big team,
including Grace for sure,
over the past semester.